foreign
Madison Wisconsin Hi Sam welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Christina thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up uh
well I'll get right to the point here
um I have my mother is 82 years old give
you a little background on her she's
she's a person who likes to have a lot
of control
she's been a good saver she has no
tolerance for risk
um she worries too much about taxes and
government
um one thing that she wants to do is she
wants to honor what my dad's wishes were
to try to have an inheritance for the
kids
that what she has accumulated she looks
at it kind of two two piles uh there's
six of us kids one is disabled so she's
set aside
money separately for her
and
um
she's she's done a really good job at
saving but really has invested next to
nothing
how much money she have
uh round numbers about four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars okay
okay
um she's got the the only thing that she
really has that's invested is
um an annuity which I think was in my
dad's retirement that appreciate what is
she living on
uh Social Security so she doesn't she
doesn't touch this money
um she's been drawing down on that
account because
um literally she's you wouldn't believe
the the cash situation but it's
basically in savings accounts or she
literally has a hundred thousand dollars
in her safety deposit box
okay that wasn't what I asked if she's
living is she living on Social Security
you said no she's drawing down on the
money
well yeah she was well she's she's
living on Social Security yes but she
also is drawing on that money because in
her mind if there's money in like that
annuity it's going to go to taxes when
she dies and suffer and I said where
does the money go when she draws it
she takes it in cash and stuffs it away
okay so she actually is meeting her
monthly needs with Social Security and
the rest of this is paranoid gyrations
it is yeah and
um between that my sister still lives
with with her she's been with her what's
the nature of your sister's disability
um she's got both some physical and
cognitive disabilities I'd say you know
she's cognitively about like what a
sixth grader might be so she will not be
taking care of herself okay now so what
what overall is your question how can we
help
well
um my mom's concerned that
um
what my her and my dad talked about
before he passed away five years ago was
he wants to be able to leave money to
the kids which I tell her he or you have
already done that because they deeded
the house over to uh kids there's not
enough
there's not enough
I'm not sure what you mean there's not
enough money to leave the kids
the disabled child is going to need the
450 000 the rest of you aren't going to
get anything
yes and what
um what her will how she's got her will
rolled up is that she has 1 6 going to
um
four of my siblings and then a third
going to me and it's always been the
understanding that that that's not
enough of what I'm getting is gonna go
towards
being able to supplement it's not just
there's care yeah it's not enough
because your sister's care is going to
take more than that
if if you bring in someone to take care
of your sister your sister's care is
going to be fifty thousand dollars a
year
yes and that that requires a five
hundred thousand dollar nest egg at 10
percent
yes so your brothers and sisters don't
need to get anything it all needs to go
to your sister
and I I would agree with that completely
and I trust and I trust and then you're
going to have to invest it wisely which
your mom is not done
yeah and I don't know that I can
convince her to do that while how can I
help you today then she's still there
um
I'm not sure one somebody uh
you know here's the thing here's what I
would do I would sit down with her and
say hey Mom
450 000 at 10 makes 45
000. that's what it's going to take to
take care of sis
nobody else needs to get anything but
CIS
you need to rewrite your will today to
leave the money into a trust assist and
I'll take care of the trust and I'll
take care of assist with that money
but none of the rest of us need to get
any money that the childish disabled
needs the money
mom you got to take care of her first
you don't have enough money to do all of
it Mom it's not there
this is plain speaking to your mom
nobody talks to your mom Blaine she runs
around acting crazy and y'all all hide
your eyes
yeah you're probably right there yeah
mom you're being crazy stop it we need
to take care of assists you need to get
this will redone because if you don't
then sis is not going to have enough
money
we have to take care of her mom this is
an emergency you're 82. we need to get
this will done this week I don't need
the money my brothers and sisters don't
need the money you have to take care of
her mom you can't be crazy anymore
you've got to do this this is what it
needs to sound like you've got to be
very piercing and kind not yell at her
but you have to you know dancing around
the way you have with me on the phone is
what you do with her and you've got to
stop that
that's good that's powerful those
conversations are hard but I mean I
think that you towed a very good
balanced line I think people have to
have the conversations and I mean maybe
you shouldn't tell your mom she's crazy
but Mom if you don't know
the conversation I thought I said quit
acting crazy but because she is acting
crazy you don't have to be crazy that
crazy I'm crazy I act crazy sometimes
I'm not crazy but the uh but yeah I mean
you're acting crazy stop it it's not
working you know this is putting money
in a safe deposit box come on I mean
seriously watching the dadgum news too
much conspiracy theory breath oh my God
the world's caving in and Trump's fault
or Biden's fault or whatever the aliens
are coming and oh my God the safe
deposit box not going to protect you
from any of that and then that getting
that money out of that safe deposit box
when she dies may be a real chore
legally
and that gun money's trapped in there
this is a horrible plan and what what
the reason you got to get the reason you
got to raise the pitch up is there's a
disabled person who's counting on this
money it's for them that we're fighting
yes that's so good and I I mean in that
situation like the mom is probably
convinced herself that she is right and
I think it's going to take one of those
very straightforward conversations
[Laughter]
well I mean you start nice like we do
here on the air and then you turn up the
heat like we do here on the air I mean
you can start nice and then by the end
of it you're like would you stop it
you're being nuts you know and just you
know you got to get seriously you got
the thing is this has been going on for
a long time and so shifting piercing
through this Behavior this fog of
weirdness is gonna take a little bit of
effort and he's he can do it he can do
it and uh I'm never suggesting you being
mean to your 82 year old Mama it's not
what I'm saying but we have to do what
she has to do what's right for this
disabled child this is too important and
if you leave this money to the other kid
another kid goes and buys a Cadillac
with it and then disabled sister doesn't
have the money to eat that's morally
wrong